in Jiu-Jitsu kaisen the movie has a
strange place in the timeline in that it
takes place before the events of season
1 but after the beginning of season 2 as
a result it can be easy to miss how
certain moments in the film directly
Connect into the main anime which is why
today I'll be explaining everything you
need to know all right so if you're
watching this you already know that in
jjk season 1 Yugi was sentenced to death
but if we rewind the clock around 10
months another student was in the exact
same position the name of that student
is UT otu and to understand why the hups
wanted to kill him is worth examining
his backstory at a super young age U was
diagnosed with pneumonia and while
receiving treatment at the hospital he
bumped into a girl called R orimoto Ric
was an orphan whose parents died in
mysterious circumstances and after their
first meeting both her and aotu ended up
going to the same school over time the
two of them became Incredibly Close to
the point where ra took her mom's old
wedding ring and used it to propose to
UTA this scene was important because not
only did he agree to to marry her in the
future but he specifically says that
they'll stay together forever when Rico
was then unexpectedly killed in a car
crash her soul morphed into a vengeful
cursed spirit that permanently attached
itself to UTA in this form R followed
him everywhere he went and for the next
six years her spirit would violently
attack anyone who she thought might be a
threat to him this is what brings us to
the very start of the jjk movie where in
November of 2016 U was being harassed by
four bullies at school in response R
crushed the bullies by buffing all four
of them into a single locker and
allegedly they managed to survive even
though the movie showed them looking
like this anyhow following this incident
jiujitsu High decides that they should
probably do something about UT and in
total they send four Sorcerers to deal
with him although the names of the
sorcerers weren't revealed we do know
that one of them was the same rank as
Toto and three others were the same rank
as fushiguro in spite of that it's
confirmed that ra took them all down
which gives you some idea of just how
powerful she is fearing what she might
do next next the hups organized UT's
execution in the Autumn of 2017 where
they plan to kill him so that R's curse
would vanish otsu agreed to this
proposal since he was tired of hurting
people and at one point he even tried to
execute himself before R stopped it from
happening with very few options left the
hups eventually called in satarug Gojo
aka the strongest sorcerer alive and his
job was to teach UT how to control the
curse after speaking with Gojo aotu then
transfers to Jiu-Jitsu High where he
joins the existing class the first year
students at the time the first years
were Mari zenin Panda and Toge unaki who
as you probably noticed were all second
years when we get around to season 1
when UT initially joined their group in
2017 the first years immediately felt
Ra's presence since she's stronger than
any curse they would have seen in their
lives the thing you need to remember
about cursed Spirits is that they're
made from a substance called cursed
energy and so the more cursed energy a
spirit has the tougher it becomes in R's
case she's described as having endless
amounts of Cur curse energy making her
essentially invincible and definitely
more dangerous than any other curse
we've seen in the anime for that reason
Mary had absolutely no respect for UT in
the beginning cuz he acts like a timid
weakling even though he has this
unbeatable curse protecting him 24/7
regardless Gojo thought it was a good
idea to send these two on a mission
together and later that day they head to
an elementary school the reason this
school is relevant is because two of the
kids recently went missing and goo
suspects that a curse was responsible a
second ago I explained how all curses
are made from curs energy but what I
didn't mention is that curse energy
itself is made from negative human
emotions what that means is that in
places like hospitals and schools where
people feel all kinds of negative
emotions it's normal for people's cursed
energy to leak out and form cursed
Spirits in these locations it's the job
of sorcerers to then exercise those
spirits and in this scene Mary
single-handedly destroys three of them
while a terrified U just watches on
following that they enter the school to
search for these missing kids and
although there are curses everywhere
none of them try to attack Mary quickly
realizes that it's because the curses
are afraid of UTA and after checking his
student ID it's revealed that he's
classified as a special grade sorcerer
which is the highest ranking that any
sorcerer can achieve in the entire world
only three other special grade Sorcerers
exist with goo being one of them so
forut to be on that level is a massive
deal in any case out of nowhere a giant
curse appears and unlike the other
Spirits this one doesn't hesitate to
attack the first year students both Mari
and aotu are then swallowed by this
thing and on the inside of his stomach
they find the missing kids who they'd
been searching for at this stage both
children were in a really bad condition
thanks to the effects of the curse and
to make things even worse Mari herself
also starts getting affected this left
UTA as the only person who could save
them which was bad news for everyone
since he still had no clue what he was
doing that's why a frustrated Mari gives
him a pep talk since their lives are
literally depending on it and luckily he
thinks of a plan soon afterwards by
putting on the engagement ring that ra
gave him it strengthens his connection
to her Cur spirit and because of that he
was able to ask to borrow her power up
until now ra would just kind of emerge
whenever she felt like it but this
occasion was the first time utas
summoned her to do something for him she
then proceeds to tear apart the other
cursed Spirit limb from limb giving U
the chance to free himself and carry
everyone else to Safety in this scene
aotu makes the decision to change as a
person and from this moment on with he
was more determined than ever to break
R's curse once the curse is broken
she'll no longer be stuck in this form
and her soul will finally be free to
pass on to the afterlife however the
challenge here is that because her
cursed spirit is basically Invincible
you can't just destroy it in the same
way you would destroy a regular curse
instead what UTA has to do is unravel
her curse step by step and I'll explain
how the basic concept is that UT's ring
enables him to borrow small parts of
Ra's curse and so once that's done he
could Channel that tiny curse into this
Katana with enough practice the aim is
to keep channeling larger and larger
amounts of R into the sword until her
spirit is fully under his control and
once that happens the curse will
officially be broken as a side note
following the mission at the elementary
school there are two important things
you need to know number one later that
same night a mysterious figure showed up
at the school and based on his shadow we
can tell that this is suguru G 11 years
earlier suguru was a student at
Jiu-Jitsu high and was considered to be
the strongest sorcerer alongside goo
himself back then G believed that it was
their responsibility as the strongest to
protect the weakest members of society
however in 2006 his views began to
change after a tragic incident this
incident made him realize that certain
people don't deserve to be saved but as
a sorcerer he has no choice but to
defend them anyway for that reason
ghetto eventually started questioning If
this job was worth it since he was
putting himself through hell all to
protect humans who he didn't respect in
2007 he then completed his transition to
the dark side when he massacred an
entire Village of over a 100 people by
this point he'd abandoned his philosophy
of the strong protecting the weak and
instead he now believed that the world
would be a better place if only
Jiu-Jitsu Sorcerers existed to make this
dream a reality he spent the next decade
Gathering an army of followers with the
goal of wiping out every regular human
on the planet this is where ra comes in
because as the most powerful curse if
she was on their side their mission
would suddenly become a lot more
realistic in case you don't know G's
curse technique allows him to take
control of cursed spirits and so if he
was to kill UTA then Ra's immense power
would all transfer to him consequently
suguru wanted to test the limit of her
potential hence why he laid this trap
for her at the elementary school the
second thing you need to know is that
later on when Mari and the kids were
recovering in hospital UTA came to a
realization until now he just assumed
that ra had chosen to curse him but in
reality he might have been the one who
turned her into a curse when he said
that they'd be together forever from
goo's perspective this theory was
plausible since he never understood how
a seemingly normal girl turned into the
strongest curse of the Modern Age to
find out the truth he immediately opened
an investigation into both Ra's
background and UT's background as he
hoped that this information might reveal
clues about where her power comes from
anyway flushing forward 3 months in that
time UT had been consistently training
with his Katana and even took part in
the 2017 Goodwill event the Goodwill
event is when students from the Tokyo
branch of Jiu-Jitsu High face off
against students from the Kyoto branch
and in season 1 we found out that Utah
and R took part in the 2017 Edition
according to the manga the Tokyo
students easily secured the win largely
thanks to R dominating the event which
is why you might have noticed that in
season 1 Toto was eager to get revenge
regardless following the three-month
time skip in the jjk movie goju decides
to send Utah on a mission with Toge
inumaki out of all the first years Toge
is is by far the most experienced and
his curse technique is known as curse
speech to put it simply it's an ability
that makes anything he says happen in
real life with an example being how if
he tells someone to stop moving then
that's exactly what's going to happen as
you can imagine a technique like this
could be usedful in a million different
ways but the downside is that Toge can't
have normal conversations to avoid
hurting people he only speaks using safe
words like salmon kelp and other rice
ball ingredients and at this stage in
the timeline UT didn't really understand
anything he said the two students then
traveled to the mission location which
was an abandoned shopping center full of
low-level curses the job here was for
Toge to exercise those curses by himself
while otu's role was mainly to stand
there and watch and learn before they
got started though Gojo warned you to
not to let ra out on this occasion since
the high-ups didn't really like her
unpredictability if aotu was to let her
go on another Rampage then it's possible
they tried to execute him even sooner
than expected moving on after entering
the location the first years encountered
the swarm of curses who they were sent
here to kill within seconds inumaki
destroys every last one of them by
telling them to explode and just like
that the mission was supposed to be over
however what they didn't know is that
inside of the shopping center G was
secretly watching them from a distance
on this occasion gto's objective was to
see r with his own two eyes and so he
ambushes them by using one of his cursed
Spirits the plan was for aotu to get so
overwhelmed by this that he'd have no
choice but to summon her again although
this time things played out a lot
differently than the elementary school
towards the beginning of the fight Toge
warned UT to stay away since his
inexperience made him vulnerable against
a curse of this level the problem though
is that inumaki himself was also
vulnerable due to the side effect of his
technique something you need to know
about Cur speech is that when you say
powerful words like explode or Blast
Away there's always a chance that your
throat might get damaged if that happens
the only way to keep using Cur speech is
to take throat medicine but you know
Mar's medicine fell out of his pocket
right next to the cursed spirit because
of that UT didn't want his classmate to
try and fight this thing alone which is
why they do work together to take it
down aotu kicks things off by channeling
a tiny part of RK into his Katana and
then trying to slash ghetto curse even
though the slash itself wasn't that deep
it gave youu to an opening to retrieve
the throat medicine and throw it to
inumaki after recovering his voice Toge
then exercises the curse by crushing it
to death meaning R never needed to come
out by the way I should mention that if
ghetto really wanted to he could have
just kept releasing more and more curses
but for some reason he chooses to let
the first years Escape hours later Gojo
then hears about the surprise curse that
attacked his students and he goes to
take a look around the area for himself
during his inspection he notices the
residuals left behind by Gator and as a
quick note residuals are just traces of
cursed energy that left behind when
someone uses their curse technique
because suguru and saru spent so much
time together as classmates gojou
instantly recognized these residuals and
and soon afterwards he tells the
principal at the same time ghetto
himself was making preparations for a
war against Jiu-Jitsu high and if you're
wondering how he could possibly win we
need to flash back to 2006 in that year
there was a religious group called The
Time vessel Association and also several
other groups with similar ideas when
suguru became evil he took over these
groups by force which gave him access to
money and more importantly it gave him
access to curses for the next decade he
built up a reputation for healing people
who were cursed
as his technique lets him absorb Spirits
thanks to this in the present day ghetto
has accumulated over 6,000 curses
including at least two special grades
not to mention he has an army of
followers who I already mentioned now if
he was to add R to all of this then sugu
believes he'd have a 99% chance of
overthrowing jiujitsu high once that's
done he could finally achieve his goal
of destroying all non Sorcerers as in
his mind apparently not even goo would
be able to stop him that's why in this
scene ghetto confidently arrives at the
school and declares war against all of
his former friends and teachers to be
specific he tells them that on December
the 24th 2017 he's going to unleash a
thousand curse Spirits in Tokyo and
another thousand in Kyoto with each
curse being given orders to Massacre the
name of this war is the night parade of
100 demons and if that sounds familiar
it's because in season 1 we found out
that on this night Toto played a big
role in fighting ghetto Army before we
get into that though after suguru made
his declaration of war you'd expect that
someone from Jiu-Jitsu high would try to
stop him right there and then however
although goo wanted to do something
there were two reasons why he couldn't
hurt ghetto in this specific moment the
first and most obvious reason is that
suguru threatened to kill the first
years with Sato didn't let him leave but
in my opinion there is a second reason
we need to factor in personally I think
it's fair to say that Gojo is fast
enough to have killed ghetto before
anything happened to his students but if
he did that there's a chance that all
6,000 of suguru curses might be released
this possibility was first mentioned by
toi fushiguro who refused to kill ghetto
back in 2006 purely because he didn't
want to deal with all the curse spirits
that might come pouring out to me it's
possible if not likely that Gojo came to
a similar conclusion and therefore
allowed his former best friend to fly
away moving on to December 24th in both
Tokyo and Kyoto jitu High had gathered
nearly every sorcerer they had their
mission was to exercise all 2,000 curses
heading their way but noticeably Utah
was left back at school due to Ra's
unpredictable nature there was a risk
that if she was on the battlefield she
might end up destroying both sides as a
result it was safer to just leave aotu
behind which is exactly what ghetto
thought was going to happen all along
the true objective of the night parade
of 100 demons was for all the
experienced sorceress to be distracted
in Kyoto and Tokyo while UTA is left
completely alone with that being the
case ghetto casually marches into J
Jitsu High where the only one left
standing between him and akatu is maki
from ghetto point of view this is
exactly the type of person who he wants
to eradicate and so he quickly wipes her
out with these stiped looking Cur
Spirits meanwhile over in Tokyo goo
begins to wonder why suguru isn't on the
front lines and as he's thinking he
suddenly gets interrupted I mentioned
earlier in the video how satu requested
an investigation into UT's background
and in this scene he finally gets the
results after hearing this info it
causes him to realize where ghetto has
to be and so he teleports Toge and Panda
back to Jiu-Jitsu High I should point
out that this move from Gojo was
extremely calculated since he knew these
two never had a single chance of
defeating ghetto instead the reason he
sent them back is that he assumed they
would lose and he was hoping this would
trigger aotu to get even stronger
luckily for Gojo that's exactly what
happened because when aotu found his
classmates lying in a bloody mess he
instantly allowed ra to come out they
both then easily destroyed a swarm of
curses that suguru sent towards them
before taking a quick break to heal the
other firste students the significance
of this moment is that it showed UTA
using reverse curse technique which is a
skill that even goo struggled to learn
at a similar age reverse curse technique
is when you take negative energy and
multiply it with more negative energy to
create a positive energy that can heal
the body overall it's a complex thing
that nearly all Sorcerers fail to
accomplish so for you to Tod do it
already after a few months it proves
that he is a special talent following
that g tries to take him down by
unleashing another horde of curses but
this time aotu counters it by using
cursed speech historically cursed speech
is a power that belongs to the inumaki
clan but without going into spoilers UT
was able to replicate it thanks to a
combination of R's help and his own
curse technique which wasn't specified
in the movie itself and he exercises all
these Spirits by ordering them to die
now back in Tokyo goo was busy fighting
against Miguel who's an African Sorcerer
And one of gto's strongest followers
Miguel's job was to stall satu for his
as long as possible so that his boss
would have enough time to finish the job
of capturing ra you might be curious how
Miguel was able to survive this long in
a battle against Gojo and the answer is
that he has a special weapon known as
the black rope the black rope has the
effect of disrupting or canceling
someone's curse technique meaning satu
wasn't able to use Limitless to its full
potential an interesting detail is that
although it took decades to make the
black Robee it quickly burned away
during this fight until there was
literally none left by the end of the
movie separately in a nearby location
ghetto other followers were causing
chaos and these two girls are basically
his adopted children 10 years ago when
suguru massacred The Village the reason
he did that is because he found that
some villagers were abusing mimiko and
nanako this was the key breaking point
where he chose to prioritize the lives
of sorcerers over the lives of humans
and they've been raised by him ever
since speaking of G back at jiujitsu
high he decides to personally fight you
to himself and if you've watched season
2 you'll notice that the curse in his
shoulder used to belong to toi back in
the day toi used this curse to store
weapons inside of it and when suguru
gain control of the curse after toi's
death he gained nearly every tool that
toi had one of those tools was a weapon
known as playful cloud and with ghetto
skill he successfully used it to hold
off R and UTA simultaneously however in
the end aotu unlocks yet another level
of his potential when he hits the
villain with black flash as you might
know black flash is a power up that
increases the strength of an attack by
way more than double and it requires an
unbelievable amount of concentration
according to Toto black flash occurs
when a sorcerer makes contact and then
adds cursed energy to that contact
within
0.0000001 seconds being that precise is
the only way this power can be unlocked
which is why no sorcerer in the world
can just use it whenever they want while
we're on the topic of black flash over
in Kyoto nanomi Unleashed four black
flashes in a row against these cursed
spirits and in the process broke the
world record at the same time Toto was
in another part of Kyoto and he
single-handedly destroyed a special
grade curse in addition to five grade
one curses to do all of that without
help is a ridiculous achievement and it
clearly helped his reputation since
fucha guro already knew who Toto was
before they even met anyway switching
over to jiujitsu high after recovering
from a black flash to the face ghetto
realizes that it's time to stop holding
back in order to kill utter once and for
all he summons this legendary special
grade C Cur and based on the context
it's safe to assume that this is the
most dangerous curse he has following
that suguru then combines every last one
of his remaining curses creating a black
mass of pure cursed energy this move is
known as a maximum technique which as
the name suggests is when a sorcerer
Taps into to the maximum potential of
what their technique can achieve in
ghetto case the overwhelming strength of
4,000 curses plus a legendary curse
Spirit it should be enough to crush
anyone including UT his current level
that being being said it was confirmed
in the jjk manga that there is one
method for any sorcerer to quickly
improve and it relates to binding vows a
binding vow is a contract where you
sacrifice one thing in order to gain
something else and for jiujitsu
Sorcerers the quickest way to level up
is to offer your life as the sacrifice
realizing that he doesn't have what it
takes to defeat gh's maximum technique
Utah offers up his life to R so that
they'll both be dead and then can be
together in the afterlife in exchange he
gains full control control of her
unlimited cursed energy which manifests
in the form of this purple orb one
second later he and G then try to kill
each other and the resulting explosion
is so intense it creates a mushroom
cloud of pure cursed energy and leaves
this giant crater behind ironically
though both Sorcerers do end up
Surviving this Death Match although it's
fair to say sugru suffered the most
damage as he limps away from the battle
he remarks that Ra's power can change
the world and that next time he'll add
her to his collection however before he
can get get away satu finally shows up
at the school and you can tell from gh's
expression here that he quickly accepts
he's about to die during their final
conversation we learned that all of
Sugar's followers managed to escape
without being captured while goo
confirms that he knew togi and Panda
would lose to G but he still trusted
that his old friend wouldn't kill them
when we look at this scene in the
context of how close they used to be it
is sad how their lives went in such
drastically different directions
considering that when they were in
school sug always used to be the
righteous one who cared about protecting
Humanity for him to now be the one in a
position like this isn't something that
I don't think either of them would have
predicted but at the very least it is
Meaningful that goo is his executioner
instead of it being UTA who he barely
knows just before satu finishes him off
he says something that we as an audience
don't hear but based on the clues that
we've gotten from the author it's likely
that he said that GTO is still his one
and only friend following that suguru
gets executed by Gojo's Limitless curse
technique while in a different part of
the school an unconscious Utah wakes up
because of the contract that he made
with r accot who was fully expecting to
die in this moment but in a surprising
turn of events that doesn't end up
happening instead Ra's Spirit abruptly
turns back into her human self for the
first time since she died and Gojo
arrives just in time to explain why 3
months ago when they first opened the
investigation into UT's past jiujitsu
High had to dig really deep to find out
the truth what they eventually
discovered is that aotu is the
descendant of Mizani sugua who was a
legendary Jiu-Jitsu sorcerer from a
thousand years ago if you want to know
more about Mizani then I'd highly
recommend watching my other video where
I explain his backstory and his
connection to the Gojo Clan but for now
the main point is that he was insanely
powerful that's why in the present day
UTA has more cursed energy than any
other living human even more than Gojo
but because his family aren't Sorcerers
he was never taught how to control it
therefore when R was hit by a car otu
refused to accept her death and since he
was untrained his cursed energy awakened
and flowed out of him transforming her
into this monster to put it another way
all the unlimited curs energy that ra
has originally belonged to UTA but it
passed to her when he accidentally made
her into a curse however now that he's
accepted her death and gained full
control of her curse energy which is
what he was trying to accomplish from
the beginning otu has done everything he
needed to unravel the curse this is why
ra transforms back to normal and
naturally UT felt incredibly guilty for
causing all of this trouble thankfully
ra didn't really care in fact it sounded
like she enjoyed her time as a cursed
spirit and as she passes on to the
afterlife she warns aotu not to join her
anytime soon implying that ra wants him
to have a long life even if it means
that they're not together after this
incident UT stays on as a student at
Jiu-Jitsu High while the topic of him
being executed is never mentioned again
you might then be wondering why don't we
see him during season 1 given that all
of his classmates were at the 2018
Goodwill event the answer to that can be
found during the movie's post-credit
scene where utter is seen chilling with
Miguel in a foreign country according to
the fan book after ghetto followers
escaped godra went out of his way to
track down Miguel and forced him to
train UTA Miguel wasn't really in a
position to say no but despite that he
gets along well with aotu despite
everything that happened with ghetto
without going into spoilers there is one
other reason why godo wanted utter to
spend time with Miguel and it's why they
went on this trip to Africa in 2018 in
fact in the opening credits for season 1
we even got this brief shot of them
walking together as it was the anime's
way of hinting what aotu was up to while
everyone else was at school with all
that said that was the whole of the jjk
movie explained in around 25 minutes or
less and if you enjoyed this video then
I appreciate if you hit that sub button
so you don't miss out on future content
like this also don't forget to hit that
like button as it does help out with the
algorithm and everything else and until
the next one peace peace out